dallas kaikel on the hill on for his
18th start looking for his eighth win as
cra four and a quarter
and cruz takes ball four and that'll
bring up donald trump
struck him out on a change up
and sevy just whips it down to third
base for good measure
benny ober making his ninth start in his
first major league win against these
white sox
up the middle nice snare by polanco and
cinderella dropped the ball cenote could
not hang on
and t.a safe at first
breaking ball gets a strikeout
jose abreu got himself an rbi double and
a home run one in each end of the double
header
catapults this ball into right center
field this is up the alleyway and jose
abreu
drives anderson around third tim is home
on double number 250 in jose abreu's
career
here's brian goodwin the cleanup man
[Applause]
goodwin left center field this is
ticketed for grass jose's around third
the throw is cut off
two nothing early
last night has carried over
to tonight
there's kepler
kepler drives it to right field lifting
it down the line and
gone a home run
kepler pulling it right down the line
for his 11th of the year that's how you
break out of a
0 for 16 i believe is what we showed
right there a good swing from him he
stayed on that ball
got himself something up
have a breakthrough moment like that
off of kykel's backside and arise is
going to
beat it out on a heck of a play by kykel
one and two from dallas kykel here and
that ball is hit in the air for center
angle is back on it adam and his
scramble makes the catch now the infield
will
be able to play back and they'll shift
to the right against mancata
[Applause]
in the air center field celestino at the
track and the wall bring him home
johan monkana surge continues
this his eighth home run things are
starting to heat up and he's now driven
in 44 runs
wave and a miss on the cutter and one
down here
kaikel strikes out kepler
book and strikeouts for dallas in a one
two three fourth inning
it's outside strong take for a lead-off
walk
and ober blows them away with a fastball
first pitch to center and that's over
the head of angle and it bounces into
the crowd for an opening double
and that's a nice walk for celestino and
he'll get the tying run to the plate
first and second nobody out for simmons
here is simmons so ground ball to first
his first time up
[Applause]
crack to the right field corner and down
for a hit so no to third they're going
to wave them around
and the throw coming through but it's
offline and simmons makes it a 4-2 ball
game and the twins have runners at first
and third with nobody
out called strike three sinker painted
him and a big first out for dallas
[Music]
so angle playing shallow on the approach
is there to make the catch engel's throw
is cut off and that will keep the third
run from scoring on a nice play from
adam celestino didn't have much of a
chance in shallow center for engel owen
two
and he struck him out it's a high cutter
to end the inning dallas keiko three
base runners then three straight out
anderson lifts it high deep kepler back
and makes a leaping catch
and then plants himself into the wall
that's a brilliant play
from the son of two ballet dancers
hit well to left field
and goodwin watches it leave
donaldson cranks number 15
and it's a 4-3 ball game got himself in
a hitters count got himself a fastball
right about belt high turned on it
didn't miss it struck out the first
couple at bats but one big swing is
sometimes all you need and you got
yourself for one swing away if you're
the minnesota twins
again left center field for juwan off
the united airlines side johan on his
way to second base and he is in there
standing up he is smashing the baseball
right now
at three for three leory garcia from the
right-hand side
after two strikeouts tonight he'll take
it
[Applause]
yeah another slider that's ball four
adam didn't see very much at all in the
way of fastballs and the bases are
loaded
[Applause]
donaldson has a play infield fly rules
goal
there's a big second out and alexander
coleman will come in to try to strand
the bases full
dribbled to colemay sets
fires and got him
a good reach by suno a good fielding
play by colemay and the white sox leave
them full
missed inside and there's a walk
[Applause]
missed wide
first base is filled with a two out walk
crews in the air to laugh and a sliding
drive is good
good win
inning over
off the bat that looked like a tie ball
game and brian goodwin throws in a life
raft
here's donaldson
first pitch stroke to left the twins get
the tying run on
and now polanco over three his flight
out bounced out struck out
a drive to right field it is back and go
on a home run
polanco's 13th of the year and the twins
take an eighth inning lead
well he squared around to bunt to start
off the at-bat and through that idea in
the trash and went around and hit this
ball into the bullpen in right field
big swing right there from polacco
he did get to first third walk tonight
for adam engel
and zach collins will swing it
[Applause]
that's ball four of us outside all
collage lost the zone and the sox have
two one with one out
and now we'll see what tony larussa
decides to do it looks like he's going
to send up andrew vaughn
two and one
andrew pokes it to right center this is
down
angle had to wait he's still coming home
throw to the plate
is not in time
we are tied
oh joe mc ewing a risky send
and it's a jackpot
so robles will be asked to face hamilton
as just a right-handed batter these days
that is true it's a base hit
warnick up with it late collins around
third the sox have taken the lead
they've got a 6-5 lead and the batter is
jose abreu 0-1
no play for larnick it's 9-5
there's another millionaire on the moon
that was a towering fly ball that just
wouldn't come down
and jose
who improbably is a single
shy of the cycle tonight
just took it out of the ballpark liam
hendricks coming out for the 42nd time
1-2
slider in a check swing
monkatta
i think they want to take a look at it
to me
it literally looked like he got him out
yeah this should be it again i mean
that's what it looked like to me it
looked like they beat him by an eyelash
at first bait
upon further review the sox
win one of the craziest games
you're gonna see